leadership and management are really
totally different things leadership is
what is hard or what is impossible or
what can't be done and why we're gonna
go do it here's my vision here's where
we're going here's the city on the hill
here's the mountain that we're trying to
climb dance leadership management is
okay hey let's get the let's get all the
cars together do we have enough food
everybody take your bathroom break you
know when we stop in a half-hour okay
all right now it's gonna take us 17
hours to get to the top of the mountain
let's go that's the difference between
leadership and in management so in terms
of a leadership style I've always
focused on hey what's the what's the
vision my company the Lance comm we're
trying to do something really really
different than the other 45,000 job
related companies that have been started
so we're doing something really
different we're doing it for a reason
and why is it important to people what
is it that we're trying to do why why
should you be here so that's my
leadership style management style is
really more focused around what are what
is it that we actually have to
accomplish great you're gonna go do that
fantastic you're gonna get back to me by
when okay that's the deadline what's the
what's the thing that you're going to do
for me you know so dates and deadlines
and and details are an important part of
Management as opposed to leadership and
they're both important but in
entrepreneurial settings leadership is
particularly important